Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, whatever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are diving into a question that I'm going to almost guarantee has probably come up for every single one of us right now, whether you are in a long-term, stable, committed relationship, whether you have just started dating someone new, you're single now, you're somewhere in between. The question is, how do I know whether this
大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s）。在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理的影响。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到本播客。无论你是新听众、老听众，还是来自世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一同剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我们要深入探讨一个我敢打包票，我们每个人此刻都可能遇到过的问题：无论你是处于长期、稳定、坚定的恋爱关系中，还是刚开始和某人约会，或者现在单身，亦或是介于两者之间。这个问题就是：我怎么知道这个人是对的人？
person is the one? How do I know I'm in the right relationship? How do I know and how will I know that someone is it for me? It's a very, I would say, anxiety-inducing question. Who we choose to be in a relationship with is, you know, life-defying. And even if you don't necessarily believe in the idea of the one or you're skeptical of the idea of a soulmate, there is still some kind of irrational part of ourselves that really questions whether we're going to find the perfect person for us, whether that person is out there and whether the person we're with now is actually that person. How can I tell that this is going to be forever? How do I know if it's going to work out? Unfortunately, you know, I can't really answer
我怎么知道我在正确的感情中？我怎么知道，又将如何确定某人就是我的真命天子？这是一个相当、可以说是容易引发焦虑的问题。我们选择和谁恋爱，你知道的，这具有决定人生意义的影响。即便你并不一定相信“真命天子”的概念，或者对灵魂伴侣的说法持怀疑态度，我们内心深处仍然有一种某种非理性的部分，真的在质疑我们是否能找到那个完美的人，那个人是否真的存在，而我们现在身边的这个人究竟是不是那个人。我怎么能看出这段感情会天长地久？我怎么知道它会不会有好结果？不幸的是，你知道的，我无法真正回答
that question for you, but it is a big one that comes up not just throughout our life, but especially in our 20s can be very natural to have doubts during this decade. You know, you are so young and there are so many people out there and you're constantly being told that. And so if the person that you're with right now isn't the one, well, you do kind of want to know now so you don't waste either of your time. You want to know that you, so that you can kind of explore what else is out there. Maybe you can meet someone on a deeper level or, you know, just in general, avoid regret of choosing the wrong person. So because, there is a lot of anxiety around this and also a lot of questions around what makes a relationship
你的这个问题，但这是一个重大的问题，不仅贯穿我们的一生，尤其在二十岁时，在这个十年里产生怀疑是非常自然的。你知道，你还那么年轻，外面有那么多人，而这种话你经常听到。所以，如果你现在的伴侣不是那个对的人，嗯，你其实很想现在就知道，这样你们俩就不会浪费彼此的时间。你想知道，这样你就可以去探索外面还有什么。也许你能和一个更深层次的人相遇，或者，你知道的，总的来说，避免选择错误之人的遗憾。因此，因为围绕这一点有很大的焦虑，同时对于什么才是一段好感情也有很多疑问，
good. Let's unpack this together. Like I said, I can't necessarily give you a magic formula because love is not that simple. But I do want to explore the idea of the one from a more psychological standpoint. Is it fact or fiction? How can we tell? But also, I want to explain why expert after expert will tell you that love is more than just a spark. It is about hard work. It is about compatibility. And you know, when I was younger, I used to hate that idea. Like honestly, I would be scared by that idea that love had to be work because I was like, everything else in life seems to be work. Surely love gets a pass. But, you know, the older I've gotten, the more I've found this idea quite comforting and actually really special. The idea of choosing to be with someone
让我们一起来探讨这个问题。就像我说的，我无法一定给你一个神奇的公式，因为爱并没有那么简单。但我确实想从更心理学的角度来探讨“真命天子”这个概念。这是事实还是虚构？我们怎么辨别？不仅如此，我还想解释为什么一位又一位专家会告诉你，爱不仅仅是火花。它关乎艰辛的努力。它关乎契合度。而且你知道的，当我更年轻的时候，我曾经很讨厌这个想法。老实说，我会被这种“爱必须付出努力”的想法吓到，因为我想，生活中的其他一切似乎都需要付出努力。唯独爱肯定能网开一面。但是，你知道的，我年纪越大，就越觉得这个想法相当安慰人，实际上也非常特别。选择和某人在一起的想法，
rather than it just always being seamless and someone dropping right into your lap and it working, I honestly find that the work component of it is a lot more meaningful, but there is definitely a point where the work, like you can't just turn anyone into your soulmate. There are some critical ingredients that a relationship needs, that someone needs to have in order to be not just the one, but the right kind of one for you. So we're going to explore those five crucial. signs as well as seven questions you can ask yourself right now at this very moment to determine whether this relationship is right for you. Without further ado, my lovely listeners,
而不是一切都总是天衣无缝、某人直接掉进你的怀里然后一切顺利，老实说，我发现其中的努力成分要更有意义得多，但肯定有一个临界点，关于这种付出——你不能把任何人变成你的灵魂伴侣。一段感情需要一些关键要素，一个人必须具备这些要素，才能不仅是对的人，而且是适合你的那种对的人。所以我们要探讨这五个至关重要的迹象，以及你现在、在此分秒可以问自己的七个问题，来确定这段感情是否适合你。废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，
let's get into it. This is an I-Heart podcast, guaranteed human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have any with, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
我们切入正题吧。这是一个 iHeart 播客，有真人保证。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）主持的《艰难求索》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行那些在别处实在不便展开的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难求索》。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's stress. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。“埃伦斯特雷斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次。”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建设恢复力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们决定自己采取行动。“我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。”我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听。
Let's kick things up. off by kind of dismantling this idea of the one. Let's talk through this one narrative. You know, the notion of a singular predestined soulmate, it's very captivating because A, it's like incredibly romantic and B, and it might not seem this way, but it's also rather simple. It takes a lot of the legwork out of things. You know, there is this idea that when you meet the right person, you'll just know it will click, it will work, you'll be together forever. There's no need to keep searching, there's no need to wonder, what if. But here's a bit of a reality check. I think clinging too tightly to this, you know, a beautiful idea, but clinging too tightly to
让我们开个头，通过某种方式来解构“真命天子”这个观念。让我们来讨论一下这个单一的叙事。你知道的，一个命中注定的单一灵魂伴侣的概念，非常引人入胜，因为A，它极其浪漫；B，虽然看起来可能不这样，但它也相当简单。它省去了很多跑腿的苦差事。你知道的，有这样一种观点：当你遇到对的人时，你自然就会知道，一切都会一拍即合，事情就会顺利，你们会永远在一起。不需要继续寻找，不需要去想“如果……会怎样”。但这里有一个现实检查。我认为过于紧抓这个，你知道的，一个美好的想法，但过于紧抓
this idea can actually be rather counterproductive. Why? Because it fosters a rather passive approach to love. It kind of suggests that your main job is just to discover this person, rather than to actively cultivate a relationship or to discover. yourself and what you want or be picky. It also, you know, as a secondary consequence, places a very impossible burden on one individual to fulfill all your needs, all your expectations. And it means that the moment the difficulties arise in a relationship, which they inevitably will, it can really cause us to question whether this person is the right person. Because if we have been told since we were children that love is just easy and it's
这个想法实际上会适得其反。为什么？因为它助长了一种对待爱的相当被动的方式。它某种程度上暗示，你的主要工作只是去发现这个人，而不是积极地去培养一段感情，或者去发现你自己以及你想要什么，或者去挑剔。它还，你知道的，作为一个次要后果，给某个个体施加了一个极其不可能承受的负担，要满足你的所有需求、所有的期望。这意味着一旦感情中出现困难——这是不可避免的——它真的会让我们怀疑这个人是不是对的人。因为如果我们从小就被灌输爱情是轻而易举的、
effortless and suddenly it's not, well then that kind of challenges the idea and it challenges our sense of stability. Beyond that, I do also think that the pressure to find the one definitely contributes to a lot of stigma around being single. It contributes to a sense that if you're single, you have somehow failed to, you know, complete this mission and complete your goal. And it's also this cultural script that we see time and time again that you cannot be happy and your life cannot begin until you have found the other person that was put on this planet to meet you where you're at. And I don't even think I need to get into how restrictive that is and also how completely incorrect it is as well, this idea that once that person, what happens if they, you know, they die?
不费吹灰之力的，而突然间并非如此，嗯，那就会对这个想法以及我们的稳定感构成挑战。除此之外，我也确实认为，寻找真命天子的压力绝对促成了围绕单身的许多污名。它促成了一种感觉：如果你单身，你就是在某种程度上未能完成这个使命，未能达成你的目标。这也是我们一次又一次看到的文化剧本：在你找到另一个被放在这个星球上与你相遇的人之前，你是不可能快乐的，你的人生也是不会开始的。我甚至觉得不需要去深入探讨它是多么具有限制性，以及它是多么完全错误，这种观点认为，一旦那个人——如果他们发生什么意外呢？
Like, great, you're going to live a miserable life for the rest of your life. That's not true. You know, people meet the people they think of soulmates, they pass away, they meet other people who are brilliant. Like there are so many examples of having multiple people who can fulfill you. But this narrative of the one of a soulmate can create a very intense, often debilitating pressure. It can lead to feelings of inadequacy. I actually think it can put more stress on a relationship. And our lives are stressful enough as it is. We don't need that added pressure of perfection when we first meet someone. And in fact, thinking that you will be able to tell everything you need to know about someone from that first spark and that first meeting is actually probably causing you to see
比如，太好了，你余生都要过着痛苦的生活。那不是真的。你知道的，人们遇到了他们认为是灵魂伴侣的人，对方去世了，他们遇到了其他非常优秀的人。就像有这么多的例子表明，可以有多个人来满足你。但这种关于灵魂伴侣“真命天子”的叙事会造成一种强烈且常常令人衰弱的压力。它会导致不胜任感。我甚至认为它会给一段感情带来更多压力。我们的生活本就已经够大压力了。当我们初次遇到某人时，我们不需要那种额外的完美压力。事实上，认为你能够从那最初的火花和第一次见面中，看出关于某人的所有你需要知道的事情，实际上可能正在导致你通过
someone through a very narrow lens. In fact, a 2005 study from Harvard, it's one of my favorite studies of all time. It was one of the first to actually use fMRI techniques to see what love looked like in the brain. This study found that the most primitive parts of this organ, of our brain are actually involved in that initial attraction. And those primitive parts of our brain are influenced by such an intoxicating combination of neurotransmitters, probably the most intoxicating combination you could find. When you first meet someone and you have the spark and you have the romance and the attraction, you are getting hit with dopamine, you are getting hit with adrenaline,
一个非常狭隘的视角来看待某人。事实上，哈佛大学在2005年进行的一项研究，是我有史以来最喜欢的的研究之一。它是最早使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）技术来观察大脑中爱情样子的研究之一。这项研究发现，这个器官即我们大脑中最原始的部分，实际上参与了最初的吸引。而我们大脑中那些原始的部分，受到神经递质那种令人陶醉的组合的影响，可能是你能找到的最令人陶醉的组合。当你初次遇到某人，感受到了火花、浪漫和吸引力时，你正受到多巴胺的冲击，你正受到肾上腺素的冲击，
with cortisol, with vasopressin, with oxytocin, all of which cause you to behave and think in ways that you wouldn't normally. So not only are you feeling a lot of really positive feelings, but also all of these hormones and all of these neurotransmitters are also at times deactivating the neural pathways responsible for social judgment, meaning that you can't actually assess someone clearly. All those critical, all the neural machinery that you need
受到皮质醇、加压素、催产素的冲击，所有这些都导致你的行为和思维方式不同于往常。所以你不仅体验到很多非常积极的感受，而且所有这些荷尔蒙和神经递质有时也会使负责社会判断的神经通路失去活性，这意味着你实际上无法清晰地评估一个人。所有那些至关重要的、你需要的神经机制
to make critical assessments of other people is essentially being silenced, It's being kind of suffocated by the noise of the attraction. And it's why the phrase love is blind hold so much truth. When we are only looking for a spark, we are looking at someone through a very restrictive lens. It means that we can't see them clearly. It also means that there may be other people sitting outside of that lens that we can't
来对他人做出关键评估的机制，本质上正在被压制。它被吸引力的噪音所充斥和窒息。这就是为什么“爱情是盲目的”这句话蕴含了如此多的真理。当我们只寻找火花时，我们是通过一个非常具有限制性的视角来看待一个人。这意味着我们无法清晰地看到他们。这也意味着，在这个视角之外可能还坐着其他人，是我们根本
see at all. There is an amazing book that I recommend to almost everyone, which is titled The Science of happily ever after. And in it, the author Dr. Tai Tashiro, he's a psychologist, he's an expert in interpersonal relationships. He points out that passion and chemistry, they get all the attention because they're glamorous and it's flashy and it's beautiful. But throughout all of his research, in long-term research trials, traits like agreeableness, emotional stability, conscientiousness, things that might not show up on a first date, they're actually fine. more robust predictors of long-term relationship happiness. So let's reframe. Instead of this
完全看不到的。有一本我向几乎所有人都推荐的精彩书籍，书名为《幸福婚姻的科学》（The Science of Happily Ever After）。在书中，作者泰·塔希罗（Tai Tashiro）博士是一位心理学家，也是人际关系领域的专家。他指出，激情和化学反应得到了所有的关注，因为它们光芒四射、浮华而美丽。但在他的所有研究、长期的研究试验中，像随和性、情绪稳定性、尽责性这些可能不会在第一次约会上表现出来的特质，实际上才是
cosmic lottery ticket where you find the one, let's just consider the possibility that someone becomes the one. Someone becomes the one through shared experiences, through mutual effort, and through a dedication to an evolving connection. Or consider the idea that there are actually many people who could be the right one or the right kind of one for you. The benefit of having this perspective in our 20s, particularly, I think is threefold. Firstly, it stops us from thinking that love is rare. And that means that we are going to be less restricted by a scarcity mindset in dating. We're going to be less restricted by this idea that we need to like, we need to find someone right now. Like there is someone out there and we are in a race against time to find them.
对长期恋爱幸福感更有力的预测指标。所以让我们重新构架。抛开那种中彩票般的、让你找到唯一真命天子的宇宙彩票，让我们考虑这样一种可能性：某人通过共同的经历、共同的努力以及对不断发展的连接的奉献，而成为了那个对的人。或者考虑这样一种想法：实际上有许多人都可以成为对的人，或者成为适合你的那种对的人。在我们二十多岁的时候持有这种视角，特别是，我认为有三重好处。首先，它阻止我们认为爱情是稀缺的。这意味着我们在约会时将较少受到稀缺心态的限制。我们将较少受到这种观念的限制，即我们需要——我们需要马上找到某人。就好像外面有一个人，我们在与时间赛跑去找到他们。
That's not a healthy approach to finding love, especially in a decade where love should be an addition and never something that feels restrictive. Secondly, I think it also takes us from being quite passive to being active in the quest for love. You know, you aren't just expecting someone to drop into your lap fully formed. You are looking for a co-pilot. And a co-pilot needs to be interviewed. they need to be tested. They need to prove themselves. If you are choosing a life partner, especially in your 20s when you are like an adult toddler, this person is going to hopefully
这不是一种寻找爱情的健康方式，尤其是在一个本该将爱情作为锦上添花、绝不应让人感到束缚的十年里。其次，我认为它也将我们从寻找爱情时的被动转变为主动。你知道的，你不仅仅是期望某人从天而降、完美无缺地掉进你的怀里。你在寻找一个副驾驶。而副驾驶是需要面试的。他们需要接受考验。他们需要证明自己。如果你正在选择一个生活伴侣，尤其是在你二十多岁时，当你就像一个成年幼儿一样，这个人有望
be with you for a very long time. They are perhaps going to raise children with you. They're going to make financial decisions with you. They're going to see you through major grief and job insecurity and moving house when it's just like when you've got a cold. Like they're going to see you through the worst things ever. You need a good co-pilot. You need someone who's like, willing to perform, not just someone who makes you feel gooey inside. We want both. And finally, I think the reason that this perspective is so healthy is that it allows you to value commitment just as much as you value chemistry, meaning you are also able to let go of bonds that aren't right for you. We've all had that feeling of meeting someone where, yes, you do magically click
陪伴你很长很长时间。他们可能会和你一起抚养孩子。他们会和你一起做出财务决定。他们会陪你度过重大悲痛、工作不稳定、搬家，以及当你只是感冒的时候。就像他们会陪你度过最糟糕的时刻一样。你需要一个好的副驾驶。你需要一个愿意付出表现的人，而不仅仅是那个让你内心感到黏糊糊的人。我们两者都要。最后，我认为这个视角如此健康的原因在于，它让你重视承诺，就像你重视化学反应一样，这意味着你也能够放手那些不适合你的羁绊。我们都有过那种感觉：遇到某人，是的，你确实与某人神奇地一拍即合，
with someone and it's sensational and you are talking all night and you are telling your friends about them and you think that you've found the one, but they're not ready. They're not ready for commitment. If we believe that there is only one person for us, we will continue to pursue that person and hold on tightly to the possibility of this person, even when it hurts and even when it gets in the way of a more healthy connection. But when you see love as an equation, an equation that also requires reciprocity, shared values, commitment, hard work. It's a lot easier for you to let that person go and to kind of carry on with your
而且感觉轰轰烈烈，你们聊了一整夜，你跟你的朋友们谈论他们，你以为你找到了真命天子，但他们还没准备好。他们还没准备好做出承诺。如果我们相信世界上只有一个人适合我们，我们就会继续追求那个人，紧紧抓住这个人的可能性不放，即使这很痛苦，即使它挡了更健康的连接的道。但当你把爱看作一个方程式，一个同样需要互惠、共同价值观、承诺、艰辛努力的方程式时。你就会更容易放手那个人，继续你的人生
life. Now, I know this might not be, you know, the romantic take that you were expecting, but I will say, just because personally I don't think that there is one soulmate or one person for each of us, does not mean that you can just pick up anybody on the street and turn them into the love of your life. That is not what I am arguing for. There are still some very critical things. needed to make a relationship work and some very deep emotional compatibility factors that will determine the long-term success of your relationship. And these are things that you can actually begin to notice very early on. And yet, when we look at couples who end up breaking up versus the ones who stay together, we see that those same things that you could have noticed at month
旅程。现在，我知道这可能不是你所期望的，你知道的，那种浪漫的看法，但我得说，仅仅因为我个人不认为我们每个人都有一个灵魂伴侣或一个特定的人，并不意味着你可以在街上随便抓一个人，然后把他们变成你一生的挚爱。那不是我的论点。让一段感情长久仍然需要一些非常关键的要素，以及一些深刻的情感契合因素，它们将决定你恋爱关系的长期成功。而这些是你在很早的时候就能开始注意到的事情。然而，当我们观察那些最终分手的伴侣与那些长相厮守的伴侣时，我们会发现，那些你在第零个月
zero or month three are the ones that cause them to divorce and break up. So I want to talk about these factors. I've been teasing this for the whole start 15 minutes of this episode. Let's talk about those five signs that someone is right for you. The first critical sign is that they are excited about your life and you are excited about their life, not just in the early days, but when things do become more monotonous. We've already explained how, you know, in the early days, your attraction to someone is naturally heightened. That's maybe one word for it. You're obsessed with them. Basically, during those early periods, You are naturally excited by the novelty of this person and they just contain all of this newness,
或第三个月就能注意到的相同事情，正是导致他们离婚和分手的元凶。所以我想讨论这些因素。我在本集开头的十五分钟里一直都在卖关子。让我们来谈谈那五个标志，证明某人确实适合你。第一个关键标志是：他们对你的生活感到兴奋，你也对他们的生活感到兴奋，不仅在早期是这样，而且当事情变得更加单调时也是如此。我们已经解释过了，你知道的，在早期，你对某人的吸引力自然会增强。这是其中的一种说法吧。你对他们着迷。基本上，在那些早期阶段，你自然会因为这个人的新鲜感而感到兴奋，他们身上包含着所有这些新奇之处，
you know, new stories, new interests, new traits, there's new people in your life that come in the door with them. That newness is really what defines the honeymoon period. The honeymoon period of like bliss, where there's no conflict, there's no fighting, everyone's really happy. All you do is like just talk and just like make out and just do fun things. That only lasts like six to 18 months. Like neurologically, people will say, oh, you know, our honeymoon period never ended. It did. Like, the way your brain, you know, thinks about this person and reacts to them and interprets them does change. But what takes over is something deeper.
你知道的，新的故事、新的兴趣、新特质，有新的人随着他们走进你的这种新奇感，正是定义了蜜月期的东西。那种没有冲突、没有争吵、每个人都非常快乐的蜜月期的幸福感。你所做的只是聊天、亲热，做一些有趣的事情。那只能持续大约六到18个月。从神经学上讲，人们会说，哦，你知道的，我们的蜜月期从未结束。其实结束了。大脑思考这个人的方式、对他们的反应以及对他们的解读确实改变了。但接管的是更深层的东西。
And when the honeymoon period is over is when you do start to see a change in the relationship. And it's when the relationship either grows or breaks apart. And what determines what. what category or what road you're going to go down is something so small you might not even notice it. It's called bids for attention. So this is a concept that was highlighted by psychologist Julie and John Gottman. They're a couple. They are basically like the leading experts in relationship stability.
而当蜜月期结束时，你确实开始看到感情发生了变化。也就是感情要么成长，要么破裂的时候。决定你将走向哪一类或哪条道路的，是一个非常微小、你甚至可能都不会注意到的细节。它被称为“对连接的示好”（bids for attention）。这是一个由心理学家朱莉·戈特曼（Julie Gottman）和约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）夫妇强调的概念。他们是一对伴侣。他们基本上是关系稳定性的顶尖专家。
They founded a lab. It's called the Love Lab. Great name. Would have been great for like a bar as well or even a podcast Love Lab. So cute. And it's one of the first couples therapy clinics. It was opened in Washington in the 80s. Julian John Gottman, they literally created the idea of a healthy relationship.
他们创立了一个实验室。它被称为“爱情实验室”（The Love Lab）。好名字。用在酒吧甚至播客上也会很棒，叫“爱情实验室”。太可爱了。这是最早的夫妻治疗诊所之一。它于20世纪80年代在华盛顿开业。朱莉和约翰·戈特曼，他们字面意义上创造了健康关系的理念。
Like, no, they were not the first ones to have a healthy relationship, but they were the first ones to label it, to want to know what it looked like from the inside, and to really try and convince people that it was something they could obtain and something that was important to understand. And they discovered these bids for connection. and they're really what defined the relationships that lasted in the couples that they saw and the ones that didn't. For example, imagine you come home from work one day and you say to your partner, oh my God, Becky from work was just so annoying. She was so annoying. And your partner goes,
不，他们并不是第一个拥有健康关系的人，但他们是第一个将其贴上标签、想要了解它从内部看起来是什么样，并真正试图说服人们这是可以获得的、且值得去理解的事物的人。他们发现了这些“连接的示好”。它们真正定义了在他们所看到的伴侣中哪些关系持久了，哪些没有。例如，想象一下，你有一天从工作回家，对伴侣说：“天哪，工作的贝基太烦人了。她太烦人了。”而你的伴侣说：
oh, that's a bummer. That's all they say. You're going to feel a little bit rejected. You're going to feel a little bit silenced in that moment, right? Now instead, imagine if they said, oh, not again. like, what's she up to this time? Tell me all about it. Like, what was your boss saying? What was she doing? This kind of response is basically saying, I hear you, I see you, I'm excited about your life. And in those moments, that person is turning towards you, not just with their body, but with their reaction. They're inviting you closer in. Couples who remain together, and not just together, but together and happy, they turn towards each other's bids for. connection at a significantly higher rate compared to those who eventually separate.
“哦，真扫兴。”这就是他们说的全部。那一刻你会感到有点被拒绝。你会在那一刻感到有点被压制，对吧？现在换个想象，如果他们说：“哦，不会吧。她这次又想搞什么名堂？快跟我讲讲。”“你老板当时说什么了？她在干嘛？”这种回应基本上是在说：我听到了，我看到了，我对你的生活感到兴奋。在那些时刻，那个人不仅用身体向你转过来，还用他们的反应向你转过来。他们在邀请你靠得更近。那些能够维持关系、并且不仅在一起而且过得幸福的伴侣，他们转向对方连接示好的频率
So the couples who stay together, they match 86% or meet 86% of these bids for connection compared to couples who separate at 33%. How you respond to your partner's everyday attempts to engage, whether it's a comment about their day or a shared observation, is really important. Even if what they're saying isn't the most exciting thing, you should be excited by the fact that they're the one saying it. And that's our first question to really determine if you're with the right kind of one for you.
要显著高于那些最终分开的伴侣。所以，能走到一起的伴侣，他们对这些连接示好的回应或满足率达到了86%，而最终分开的伴侣只有33%。你如何回应伴侣日常中想要互动的尝试，无论是关于他们一天的评论，还是共同的观察，这都非常重要。即使他们说的话并不是最令人兴奋的事情，你也应该为说这话的人本身感到兴奋。这就是我们的第一个问题，用来真正确定你是否与适合你的那种人在一起。
Are you at the end of the day interested in their life and are they interested in yours? The next sign is something that we kind of, I would say, brush over a lot, but who'd end up being kind of like the undoing of a relationship if we aren't careful? It's values. And not just values in terms of religious beliefs or having the exact, same kind of personality. It's deeper than that. It's do you see the world in a similar way to me? Do you have the same idea of love, the same idea of a good life, the same ideas of justice and fairness and kindness and work ethic? Those are really critical. Now obviously, you know, you aren't
归根结底，你对他们的生活感兴趣吗？他们对你的生活感兴趣吗？下一个标志是我们某种程度上、可以说是经常轻描淡写，但如果我们不小心的话，最终会成为摧毁关系的罪魁祸首。那就是价值观。不仅仅是关于宗教信仰或拥有完全相同的性格之类的价值观。它比那更深层。它是：你看待世界的方式和我相似吗？你对爱有相同的看法，对美好生活有相同的看法，对正义、公平、善良和职业道德有相同的看法吗？这些真的很关键。现在很显然，你知道的，你不会
going to go on a first date and immediately like sit down and ask someone, so who did you vote for? Or do you want kids? Or what's the biggest issue facing humanity? If you want to, though, go ahead. Like, I would love to know if you do that what their answers are. But it's about being aware of the fact that values and your moral standpoints are just as important as hobbies, similarities, attraction, all of those things. And I'm going to tell you why. So a 2016 study basically found that a lack of shared beliefs between a couple increased the risk of divorce by almost 19%. that's a lot of percent, 19 of them. Like, that's, that's, I'm not, I'm not betting on those chances.
在第一次约会上立刻坐下来问某人：那么，你投了谁的票？或者你想要孩子吗？或者人类面临的最大问题是什么？不过，如果你想这么做，那就去吧。就像，如果你这么做，我很想知道他们的回答是什么。但关键是要意识到，价值观和你的道德立场与爱好、相似性、吸引力等所有这些东西一样重要。我要告诉你为什么。因此，2016年的一项研究基本上发现，伴侣之间缺乏共同信仰会使离婚风险增加近19%。这是一个很大的百分比，19个百分点。就像，那是，那是我不会去押注的几率。
And an even more recent study that was actually conducted this year 2025, it looked at over 300 married couples and it asked them to rate their own values, rate their spouse's values, and how satisfied they were at the end of the day in their marriage. Those who not only shared each other's values, but contributed to how they were expressed in the other person, i.e. they gave them opportunities to be generous. They gave them opportunities to be creative, to be a leader. They were much happier in that relationship. This phenomena that we have been describing it has a name. It's called value congruence theory. When two people share similar values, they are more likely to make similar decisions and therefore they are less likely to resent the other
而另一项更新的研究实际上是在今年2025年进行的，它调查了300多对已婚夫妇，要求他们评估自己的价值观、评估配偶的价值观，以及他们对婚姻最终的满意度。那些不仅分享彼此的价值观，而且还促进这些价值观在对方身上表达的人，例如：他们给对方提供慷慨的机会。他们给对方提供发挥创造力、成为领导者的机会。他们在那种关系中要幸福得多。我们一直在描述的这种现象有一个名字。它被称为“价值观契合理论”（value congruence theory）。当两个人分享相似的价值观时，他们更有可能做出相似的决定，因此也就不太可能怨恨对方。
person. That resentment is really just fuel for conflict, for arguments, for deep, moral and personal tension. So you're avoiding a whole lot of that. The question that I think gets straight to the heart of this, I think it's an incredible litmus test if you're kind of at like a fork in the road with your relationship. If you were suddenly in a coma for two years, would you be happy for your partner to run your life for you? Would you trust their decisions? If you want to have kids as well, I know this question might not be for everyone, but if kids are on the cards for you, they're something that you want. You can also apply this question to that future hypothetical as well. Would this person be the kind of parent I would want my kids to have? Would they teach them the values and the lessons
这种怨恨实际上只是冲突、争吵以及深层道德和个人紧张的燃料。所以你可以避免很多这样的情况。我认为能直击核心的问题是，如果你在感情中处于十字路口，这绝对是一个极佳的试金石。如果你突然陷入昏迷两年，你愿意让你的伴侣为你主宰生活吗？你信任他们的决定吗？如果你也想要孩子，我知道这个问题可能不适合所有人，但如果生孩子在你的计划中，它们是你想要的。你也可以将这个问题应用到未来的那个假设中。这个人会是我希望我的孩子拥有的那种父母吗？他们会教给他们我认为重要的价值观和教训吗？在我们二十多岁的时候，不去过多地思考这些事情是非常容易的。你知道吗？我懂的。
that I think matter? It is very easy in our 20s to not think about these things very, very much. And you know what? I get it. Like relationships are meant to be fun and passionate and spontaneous. And in the moment, sometimes you don't bring up moral, moral imperatives or moral questions or big philosophical deep things. But they are things that you can notice. And when you get serious about someone, you also have to get serious about what drives them in life. And also the fact that there are some things that you cannot change about them. And you shouldn't have to change either. Those values matter. Find a way to discern them.
恋爱本该是充满乐趣、激情和冲动的。有时候，在当下的那一刻，你不会提起道德上的、道德层面的问题，或者宏大的哲学深奥事情。但这些都是你能注意到的事情。当你对某人认真时，你也必须认真对待是什么在驱使他们的人生。还有这样一个事实：有些关于他们的事你是无法改变的。而且你也不应该去改变。这些价值观很重要。找到一种辨别它们的方法。
Find a way to make sure that you are aligned. Okay, my lovely listeners, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, what are the three final signs that they are the right kind of one for you? And also, let's get to those seven questions that you can ask yourself right now if you want to be able to tell, is this person right for me? So stick around. We'll be right back after this short break. 2%.
找到一种方法来确保你们步调一致。好了，我可爱的听众们，我们要稍事休息，但当我们回来时，究竟是哪三个最后的迹象表明他们是适合你的那种人？另外，让我们来看看那七个你现在就可以问自己的问题，如果你想知道的话：这个人适合我吗？所以请留步。我们稍事休息后马上回来。2%。
That is the number of people who take the state. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建设恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交流，
and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
等等，去审视那些统治着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed Correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作嘉宾的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。说清楚点，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难求索》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在说。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它，却不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难求索》中，我们就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《艰难求索》（Learn the Hard Way）并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。“埃伦斯特雷斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. The West B and Michael Marantini.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。“我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。”阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男人：韦斯特·B（The West B）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Amaricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马icopa县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这还没完。在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。
Welcome back. Let's get straight into it. I don't know about you, but I have heard a lot of couples talk about how they don't really argue. You know, they don't really fight. They haven't had a conflict in five years of being together. Maybe people will come at me for saying this, but I always think someone's lying in the situation. Either you are lying to me or your partner or one of you is lying to the other one about their true feelings. Because healthy couples and And people who are meant to be with you, like, they fight and they fight well. That's our third sign for today is that when you're with the right person, miscommunications and arguments, they aren't deal breakers, you don't shy away from them.
欢迎回来。我们直接切入正题。不知道你们怎么样，我听过很多伴侣谈论他们其实不怎么吵架。你知道的，他们其实不怎么打架。在一起五年都没有过冲突。也许人们会因为我说这话而抨击我，但我总是觉得这种情况下有人在说谎。要么你在对我撒谎，要么你的伙伴在撒谎，或者你们其中一人对另一人隐瞒了真实感受。因为健康的伴侣和那些注定要和你在一起的人，他们会吵架，而且吵得很好。这是我们今天的第三个标志：当你和对的人在一起时，误解和争吵并不是交易的终结者，你们不会对它们退避三舍。
You also do it well. And you appreciate that they are actually relationship expanders because in the occasional kind of ugliness of disagreements, like you really get to see who someone really is and you get to learn. so much stuff about, you know, things like their childhood. You get to learn about their coping mechanisms. You get to learn about how they see the world, how they deal with pain, how they deal with discomfort. Like there is so much in that. Let me explain. So being able to argue well in a relationship is essential because conflict is not only inevitable. It's also a sign of engagement, like a version of those emotional bids that we talked about before. Sometimes people
你们也处理得很得体。并且你们会感激它们实际上是“关系拓展器”，因为在偶尔有些面目可憎的争执中，你真的能看清某人真实的样子，并且你能了解关于诸如他们的童年之类的事情。你可以了解他们的应对机制。你可以了解他们如何看待世界，如何处理痛苦，如何处理不适。这里面大有学门。让我解释一下。所以，在关系中能够很好地争吵是至关重要的，因为冲突不仅是不可避免的。这也是一种参与的迹象，就像我们之前谈到的那些情感示好的另一种版本。有时人们
try and get attention through starting conflict. And if another person can learn to deal with that and understand where that's coming from, that can be a really amazing way of knowing someone better. We're also going to talk about those same researchers as we did before Dr. Julie and John Gottman and what they've had to say about white conflict is such a predictor in their minds of long-term relationship success. So they have, like I said, studied literally thousands of couples over the last decade. And what they found when it comes to conflict is that there are four different conflict or communication styles that will destroy a relationship, like almost as quickly as infidelity or anything else. These are called the four horsemen of the apocalypse. They are criticism,
试图通过挑起冲突来获得关注。如果另一个人能够学会处理这一点并理解冲突的根源，那将是更好地了解某人的一种非常了不起的方式。我们还将讨论和之前相同的研究人员——朱莉·戈特曼博士和约翰·戈特曼博士，以及他们对明智的冲突在他们心目中作为长期恋爱成功预测指标的看法。正如我所说，他们在过去十年里研究了数千对伴侣。关于冲突，他们发现有四种不同的冲突或沟通风格会摧毁一段感情，其速度几乎和不忠或任何其他事情一样快。这些被称为“末日四骑士”（four horsemen of the apocalypse）。它们是批评、
contempt, defensiveness and stonewalling. Here is a crazy number for you. These things can consistently predict divorce with over 90% of an accuracy rate. So if you have one of these things in your relationship, the Gottman's and all their research say 90% of the time, we can link that to a divorce. Let's talk through these four horsemen. The first is criticism. Criticism in a relationship. It's more than just complaining. It is attacking the person, not just the behavior. Instead of saying, like, if you live with your partner, I'm upset that you didn't do the dishes, it sounds like you're someone who is lazy and you're someone who doesn't clean up after themselves and you're someone who never helps out. So as soon as you get into an argument,
轻蔑、防御和冷暴力。这里有一个让你觉得疯狂的数字。这些因素能够以超过90%的准确率持续预测离婚。因此，如果你们的感情中出现了其中一种情况，戈特曼夫妇及其所有的研究表明，在90%的情况下，我们可以将其与离婚联系起来。让我们来聊聊这四大骑士。首先是批评。亲密关系中的批评。它不仅仅是抱怨。它是对人的攻击，而不仅仅是对行为的攻击。比如，如果你和伴侣住在一起，你不是说“我很遗憾你没有洗碗”，而是听起来像“你是一个懒惰的人，你是一个不收拾自己烂摊子的人，你是一个从来不帮忙的人”。所以，一旦你们陷入争吵，
it's not about the problem that you two are dealing with together. It's about the other person and a flaw that they have. And how is someone going to react to that? Immediately they're going to react with defensiveness or shame or sometimes like a need to get back at you. That's the first one. The second is contempt, and they say this is the most destructive of all. It involves speaking from a place of superiority. Mocking, eye-rolling, name-calling, sarcasm, things that display, disgust, things that say to someone, I'm better than you.
这就不再是关于你们两人共同面对的问题了。而是关于对方以及他们身上的一个缺点。而别人会对此作何反应呢？他们会立刻以防御、羞耻或者有时甚至是以报复的冲动来回应。这是第一点。第二点是轻蔑，他们说这是所有破坏性行为中最严重的一种。它表现为一种优越感的语气。嘲讽、翻白眼、辱骂、讽刺，这些表现出厌恶、向对方传达“我比你优秀”的事物。
You know, you are crying and you're upset at your partner, and they say, oh, God, you look so pathetic. I can't believe I have to explain this to you again. Like this is like the 20th time. I've told you you're so stupid. Now, it's when I say that it's the 20th time I've told you, it's not that you are genuinely like trying to bring up past grievances and explain like, we've talked about this before.
你知道的，你正在哭泣，对你的伴侣感到不满，而他们却说：“哦，天哪，你看上去真可怜。我真不敢相信我得再次向你解释这个。就像这是我第20次告诉你了。你太蠢了。”现在，当我说是第20次告诉你时，并不是说你真的在试图翻旧账并解释说“我们以前讨论过这个”。
It's like you are angry at someone and you are willing to cut them down for it. And you have resentment deep in your bones that is coming out through conflict. So Gottman found this is the single greatest predictor of divorce because, is it erodes the most crucial part of a relationship, which is respect. Third, we have defensiveness. Now, defensiveness is kind of, like, it's actually self-protective, but it can often sound like blame shifting or denial. So instead of taking responsibility for an action, or if you bring up a criticism,
这就好像你在生某人的气，并且愿意为此贬低他们。你的骨子里有着深深的怨恨，而这种怨恨正通过冲突宣泄出来。因此戈特曼发现这是预测离婚的最重要指标，因为，它侵蚀了亲密关系中最至关重要的一部分，那就是尊重。第三点，我们有防御心理。那么，防御心理有点像，它其实是一种自我保护，但它听起来往往像是转移责任或矢口否认。所以，与其为一个行为承担责任，或者如果你提出了批评，
instead of saying, yep, I fully own that, a defensive partner might say, like, it's not my fault that I've done this or you made me do this because of this reason or I only acted that way because you provoked me. It escalates conflict because it invalidates the other person's experiences and it avoids accountability. And so often what this research says is that people who end up doing this are actually people who are very much overly criticized as children. And so they don't want to see that criticism reflected in their relationship, but it means that when it's a valid thing to bring up, like they can't, their tolerance for it is so low that they can't even take that. So defensiveness is a third and the final one is stonewalling. And this occurs when the other
防御性的伴侣可能会说“我这样做不是我的错”或“因为这个原因你才逼我这么做的”，或者“我那样做只是因为你激怒了我”，而不是说“是的，我完全承认这一点”。它会升级冲突，因为它否定了对方的经历，并且逃避了责任。因此，这项研究经常表明，最终这样做的人实际上往往是那些在童年时期受到过度批评的人。因此，他们不想在自己的亲密关系中看到这种批评的折射，但这意味著，当需要提出一个合理的意见时，他们做不到，他们对这种批评的耐受度低到甚至无法接受这一点。所以防御是第三个，而最后一个是冷暴力。这种情况发生在另一个
partner just shuts down, goes silent, walks away, completely emotionally withdraws, that they don't want to have it out with you. I saw this thing the other day, this, I guess it was a quote, it was in like a publication. It basically said, it was from a, sorry, it was from a relationship expert slash couples counselor. And she said, the biggest sign that I know a breakup or a divorce is coming is when they don't even care about fighting anymore. When the other person just completely taps out, they don't even, they don't see there being a reason in having conflict. If it's not addressed, these things ruin a relationship, they ruin them. On the other hand, couples who replace these behaviors with empathy, who take responsibility, who are attuned to each other,
伴侣只是选择关闭自己、陷入沉默、转身离开、在情感上完全抽离，他们不想和你争辩。我前几天看到这样一件事，这个，我猜它是一句名言，它出现在某个出版物里。它基本上是说，它来自一个，抱歉，它来自一个亲密关系专家兼情侣咨询师。她说，我知道分手或离婚即将来临的最大迹象是，他们甚至不再关心争吵了。当另一个人完全放弃时，他们甚至不觉得爆发冲突有什么意义。如果不加以解决，这些事情会毁了一段关系，它们会彻底毁掉关系。另一方面，那些用同理心取代这些行为、勇于承担责任、对彼此保持高度默契的情侣，
deliberately, they tend to resolve conflict more successfully. And it actually is something that they reflect back on and say, wow, that actually really deepened our emotional bond. Can you argue well? That's really the question here. It's not about suppressing your anger. It's not about avoiding confrontation, the healthiest couples. They disagree just as much as unhappy ones. the difference lies in their use of what we call repair attempts. So they deescalate tension, they make a joke, they express affection, they clarify misunderstandings in the middle of the disagreement rather than afterwards. You know, if you accidentally like snap at your boyfriend in the car because you're really
刻意地，他们往往能更成功地解决冲突。这实际上是他们事后会回味并说道：“哇，那真的加深了我们的情感纽带。”你们能进行良好的争吵吗？这才是真正的问题所在。这并不是要压抑你的愤怒。这不是要回避冲突，最健康的情侣。他们产生的分歧和不快乐的情侣一样多。区别在于他们是否使用了我们所谓的修复尝试。因此，他们会缓和紧张气氛、开个玩笑、表达爱意、在争吵过程中而不是事后澄清误解。你知道，如果你在车里不小心对你的男朋友发脾气，因为你真的很
frustrated or angry, but then you are the first one to apologize and you really do lean over and you put your hand on his knee and you say, I'm sorry and I understand why I did that. those small moments are really powerful signals of emotional safety and that powerful signals of someone not having ego in their relationship. And that emotional safety especially is something that I think, and I wish we talked about just as much as the spark, just as much as love at first sight or butterflies, all those things are amazing. But feeling like you always have a place to kind of come home to, like you could literally
沮丧或生气，但随后你是第一个道歉的人，并且你真的靠过去，把手放在他的膝盖上，说：“我很抱歉，我明白我为什么会那样做。”那些微小的时刻是情感安全感的真正强大信号，也是一个人在亲密关系中没有自我意识的强大信号。尤其是那种情感安全感，我认为，我希望我们对它的讨论能和讨论“火花”一样多，和对一见钟情或心动的感觉的讨论一样多，所有这些感觉都是美妙的。但是，感觉你总是有一个可以归宿的地方，就像你可以字面意义上地
lay out everything on the table and they wouldn't look away from it, that's like a whole new level of intimacy. If you want to know whether someone is the right one, have a fight. See, see what happens. Okay, we're going to go in like literally the complete opposite direction now, like the furthest point left. If we have fighting at one end, you have fun and you have good times on the other. And this is sign for life feels exciting with this person, even when it's is from the outside, very, very boring. A soulmate, whether it's a soulmate you've found or a soulmate or a soul connection that you've built, brick by brick, someone that you were in a relationship who was right for you, they should ultimately make you feel lighter. And a big part of
把一切都摊开在桌面上，而他们不会移开视线，这简直是一种全新境界的亲密感。如果你想知道某人是否是那个对的人，那就吵一架。看，看看会发生什么。好了，我们现在要走向完全相反的方向，就像最左边的极端。如果争吵是一端，那么快乐和美好的时光就在另一端。这个迹象表明，与这个人在一起，生活会让人觉得充满兴奋，哪怕从局外来看，它是非常非常无聊的。灵魂伴侣，无论是一个已经找到的灵魂伴侣，还是你通过一块砖一块瓦建立起来的灵魂伴侣或灵魂连接，一个与你处于一段关系中、对你而言合适的人，他们最终应该让你感到轻松。而其中的很大一部分是
that is humor and laughing and jokes and fun. Having mundane fun with your partner, doing stupid stuff at the grocery store or giggling like kids before you go to bed. That is a powerful psychological marker of long-term compatibility. I think the reason that it is so powerful is that it shows that your connection isn't dependent on really big moments and a lot of flurry and excitement. It's really grounded in shared presence and ease and a natural sense of like childlike nature and play. Small moments, that's really what it's based on. And surprise, surprise, what is life made up of, but small moments. And so if your relationship can flow and thrive in that natural ebb of the basic things you do every day, like if your love is made up of small moments, the way that life is,
幽默、欢笑、玩笑和乐趣。和你的伴侣享受平凡的乐趣，在杂货店里做些蠢事，或者在睡觉前像小孩子一样咯咯傻笑。这是长期兼容性的一个强有力的心理标志。我认为它之所以如此强大，是因为它表明你们的连接不依赖于那些非常重大的时刻、大量的忙乱和兴奋。它真正植根于共同的陪伴、松弛感，以及一种自然的孩童般的纯真与玩耍。微小的时刻，这才是它真正立足的基础。惊喜吧，惊喜吧，生活不就是由微小的时刻组成的吗？因此，如果你的亲密关系能够在日常点滴的自然起伏中顺畅流动并繁荣发展，也就是说，如果你的爱是由无数微小的时刻组成的，正如生活本身那样，
I feel like it naturally feels so much more stable and special and easy. There's one study in particular that really captures the importance of this and I want to talk about it today. it was conducted by the psychologist Arthur Aaron. Now, you might know him from his 36 questions to fall in love experiment. If you haven't heard of this basically, he came up with these 36 questions and he posited that if you sat two people down in a room and asked them to ask, the other person these questions, questions that got increasingly intimate, these two people could easily, he could make them fall in love. And there's a very famous story. that the first time he did this experiment, literally two of the participants who had never met
我觉得它自然而然地会让人感觉更加稳定、特别和轻松。有一项特定的研究真正捕捉到了这一点的重要性，我今天想谈谈它。它是由心理学家阿瑟·阿伦（Arthur Aaron）进行的。现在，你可能从他的“让人坠入爱河的36个问题”实验中听说过他。如果你没听说过这个，基本上，他想出了这36个问题，并提出假设：如果你把两个人安排在一个房间里，让他们向对方询问这些问题，这些问题变得越来越亲密，这两个人就能很容易地坠入爱河。有一个非常著名的故事，那就是他第一次做这个实验时，字面意义上有两个以前从未见过面
each other before were married six months later. And it's become like a bit of folklore. So he's basically the closest thing that we have to a scientific matchmaker. And in the early 2000s, he did this study on how fun and novelty affects romantic satisfaction. So he got 178 couples. They answered like a newspaper ad. And half of them were asked to engage in a really novel exciting activity. I think they did an obstacle course together and the other half did like a neutral activity where they were just asked to sit and talk to each other. Those who participated in the playful novel experience, they reported significantly higher relationship satisfaction afterwards, not because of the activity itself, but because it reignited a sense of shared joy and shared
的参与者在六个月后结婚了。这已经变成了一个有点像民间传说的故事。所以他基本上是我们所能拥有的最接近科学媒人的存在。在2000年代初，他做了一项关于趣味性和新鲜感如何影响浪漫满意度的研究。因此他找来了178对情侣。他们是通过报纸广告招募的。其中一半人被要求参与一项真正新颖、令人兴奋的活动。我想他们一起完成了一个障碍训练场，而另一半人则进行了一项中性活动，只是被要求坐在一起聊天。那些参与了趣味性、新颖体验的人，事后报告的亲密关系满意度明显更高，这不是因为活动本身，而是因为它重新点燃了一种共同的快乐和共同的
spontaneity. What's fascinating, what's even more fascinating, actually I should say, is that follow-up research showed even mundane activities. If they were approached with a playful attitude had a similar effect on emotional closeness. You don't have to go out and do an obstacle course. You don't have to go out and do an extravagant date night. Just bringing that playful energy to small moments is the real powerful antidote or the real powerful substance here. It's the shared emotional tone, not the setting that I think really makes the moment
自发性。迷人的是，更迷人的其实是，我应该说，后续研究表明，即使是平凡的活动。如果以一种好玩的态度去对待，也会对情感亲密产生类似的影响。你不需要特意出门去闯障碍训练场。你不需要特意去进行一场奢华的约会之夜。只要把那种好玩的心态带入微小的时刻，才是真正强大的解药，或者说真正强有力的实质所在。我认为真正让这个时刻变得有意义的是共同的情感基调，而不是环境
meaningful. The deeper thing about fun in particular and why it's so beneficial for a relationship and so indicative of whether someone is right for you is that it is protective. Fun is protective. It acts as a shield, an emotional shield, even in bad times. The average couple who is, let's say, going to be together for 20 plus years is going to go through 20 plus really hard moments. Death, grief, financial difficulties, job insecurity, natural disasters, whatever it is, it's inevitable. Lingering on those moments is what makes life really heavy, not just the moments themselves. And the thing that fun and play does is that it actually accentuates the positive things in life so that all the good stuff feels louder and it feels grander and it feels more important than the negative
关于“趣味”本身更深层的意义，以及为什么它对亲密关系如此有益、为什么它是某人是否适合你的绝佳指标，原因在于它具有保护作用。趣味具有保护作用。它就像一面盾牌，一面情感盾牌，即使在不好的时候也能发挥作用。一对平均将在一起20年以上的伴侣，将经历20多年真正艰难的时刻。死亡、悲伤、经济困难、工作不稳定、自然灾害，无论是什么，这都是不可避免的。纠结于这些时刻，才会让生活变得沉重，而不仅仅是时刻本身。而趣味和玩耍所做的事情，实际上是强调了生活中的积极事物，让所有的美好都显得更加响亮、更加宏大、比消极事物
things. And if you have a partner who can bring that out, obviously your outlook on life is going to be better. your relationship is going to thrive under those conditions. There was this beautiful video that I saw recently from an Australian couple. They've been married for 67 years and they were being interviewed like on what's the secret to their marriage? Like everyone wants to know. And I kid you not in this video like they are canoodling. They are still totally in love like they are talking about how the other person is everything
更加重要。如果你有一个能激发出这一点的伴侣，显然你对生活的看法会更好。在这些条件下，你们的亲密关系将会蓬勃发展。我最近看到了一段来自一对澳大利亚夫妇的美丽视频。他们已经结婚67年了，人们采访他们时问到他们的婚姻秘诀是什么？每个人都想知道。我没骗你，在这段视频里，他们表现得很亲昵。他们依然深深相爱，他们谈论着对方是如何成为他们的
to them. And the wife said the most important thing is to have a sense of humor. and if you don't have that, don't even bother getting married. And that just really stuck with me. Like life is meant to be fun. Love is meant to be fun. If you're crying every day, if you can't laugh with them, if it feels heavy, that's going to make your life heavy.
一切的。妻子说，最重要的事情是要有幽默感。如果没有这个，就根本不用结婚。这句话真的深深触动了我。生活本该充满乐趣。爱本该充满乐趣。如果你每天都在哭泣，如果你无法和他们一起欢笑，如果一切都让人感到沉重，那会让你的生活也变得沉重。
So if someone is right for you, they will bring joy, they will bring lightness, they will bring laughter. Probably one of the easiest ways to say is this person going to make my life better. So we are at our final point for today's episode, the final sign that someone is the one. And it is about as simple as the sun coming up. The final sign is that you simply just admire them. You just really admire this person. I was speaking to my friend the other day about her husband and I was like, when did you know?
所以，如果一个人适合你，他们会带来快乐，带来轻盈，带来欢笑。这大概是最简单的方法之一，用来判断这个人是否会让我的生活变得更好。所以我们来到了今天这一集的最后一个要点，即某人是“对的人”的最后一个标志。它就像日出一样简单。最后的标志就是你由衷地欣赏他们。你就是非常欣赏这个人。我前几天和我的朋友聊起她的丈夫，我说，你是什麽时候知道的？
When did you know that you should marry him? She goes, I don't think I ever knew, but every single day I wake up and I just think he is the coolest person I've ever met. And I was like, wow, that is such a great way to put it. I think honestly, the best relationships, I at least believe this, are when both people think the other person is out of their league. Both people think the other person is better than the other person. It brings obviously mutual respect, but also like, if you think the other person, you think the other person, is like the coolest person in the world to steal my friend's words or like just amazing. It's going to constantly make you want to be better for them and want to show up for them
你是什麽时候知道你应该嫁给他的？她说，我想我从来没真正知道过，但每天早上醒来，我都觉得他是我见过的最酷的人。我说，哇，这真的是个绝佳的表述。老实说，我真的认为最棒的亲密关系——我至少是这样认为的——是双方都觉得对方高攀了自己。双方都觉得对方比自己更优秀。这显然带来了相互尊重，但同时，如果你觉得另一个人，你觉得另一个人，借用我朋友的话来说，就像是世界上最酷的人，或者说就是那么惊艳。这会不断地促使你想为他们变得更好，想在他们面前表现出最好的一面，
and want to keep winning them over throughout the years. When we admire our partner as well, we also see them as someone that we want to learn from and we want to grow alongside. The psychologist Carl Rogers, he calls this unconditional positive regard, valuing someone for who they are without trying to change them. And in a healthy relationship, this admiration becomes reciprocal. When both partners feel genuinely seen and respected for their strengths, it really makes both people feel worthy. It makes the partnership feel better.
并在岁月的流逝中不断赢得他们的芳心。当我们欣赏我们的伴侣时，我们也会将他们视为我们想要学习并与之共同成长的人。心理学家卡尔·罗杰斯（Carl Rogers）称之为无条件积极关注，即珍视一个人的本真，而不是试图去改变他们。在一段健康的亲密关系中，这种欣赏是相互的。当双方都因为各自的优点而被真正地看见和尊重时，这确实会让双方都感到自己很有价值。它会让伙伴关系变得更好。
Mutual admiration also fosters something we refer to as idealization. The tendency to see our partner in an idealized light, not out of delusion, but as a motivational force. So we can't idealize them to the point where, you know, things about them that are actually terrible are invisible. we want to idealize the parts of them that are amazing and in our minds become even more amazing. There was another recent piece of research that found that partners who idealized each other to a moderate degree, so seeing their partner is slightly better than they saw themselves, they did actually report greater relationship satisfaction over time. So this kind of positive illusion, it's not naive, it's not silly, it's actually a buffer.
相互欣赏还培养了一种我们称之为“理想化”的倾向。也就是以一种理想化的眼光看待我们的伴侣的倾向，这不是出于妄想，而是一种动力源泉。所以我们不能把他们理想化到这种程度，你知道的，他们身上那些实际上很糟糕的缺点变得隐形了。我们想要理想化他们身上那些惊艳的部分，并且在我们的脑海中让这些部分变得更加惊艳。最近还有一项研究发现，那些对伴侣抱有适度理想化程度的伴侣——也就是把伴侣看得比他们自己看到的稍微好一点——随着时间的推移，他们确实报告了更高的亲密关系满意度。所以这种积极的错觉，它不是天真，也不是傻气，它实际上是一个缓冲。
It's a buffer for the relationship against, you know, disappointments, against hard times, because we consistently brought back to this idea of their goodness and this idea of their potential. And it also creates a really good feedback loop. You know, if they believe that I'm great, I want to live up to it. And so I will. And then you think they're even more great. And, you know, you see where this is going. It's a positive upward spiral.
它为亲密关系提供了一个缓冲，抵御，你知道的，失望，抵御艰难时期，因为我们不断地被拉回到关于他们优秀品质的理念以及关于他们潜力的理念中。它还创造了一个非常好的反馈循环。你知道的，如果他们相信我很棒，我就想不辜负这种信任。于是我做到了。然后你就会觉得他们更棒了。而且，你知道这会导向何方。这是一个积极向上的螺旋。
So with all that in mind, with all those amazing science, that someone is the right kind of one for you. I want to give you a final list of seven questions to ask yourself when you find yourself facing this anxiety-inducing question. I know this question comes up a lot for people who have relationship anxiety and relationship OCD and we've done a whole episode on that. I'm not going to get into it, but sometimes you can logically know that someone is absolutely perfect for you and amazing and still feel this sense of doubt.
因此，考虑到这一切，考虑到所有这些关于某人是适合你的真命天子的美妙科学。我想在最后给你列出七个问题，当你发现自己面对这个引发焦虑的问题时，可以问问自己。我知道这个问题经常出现在那些有亲密关系焦虑和亲密关系强迫症（ROC）的人身上，我们曾就此做过一整集节目。我不会深入探讨这个，但有时你可能在逻辑上知道某人对你来说绝对是完美且惊艳的，但内心仍然会感受到这种怀疑。
and it doesn't mean that you're a bad partner and it doesn't mean that you should break up with them. There's so much other complex stuff going on underneath. I also think if you're a bit of perfectionist, you're really scared of the idea of settling or of something in your life not being perfect in the moment and perfect in the future. And that can cause you to look at your relationship with a lens of such intense scrutiny that, of course, you're going to find something bad with it. So in those moments, ask yourself these seven questions. And I think it will give you some clarity. Firstly, when you imagine a life without them, do you feel relieved or do you feel a sense of loss? Does a future with them feel exciting or does it feel daunting? Do they challenge me in a way
这并不意味着你是一个糟糕的伴侣，也不意味着你应该和他们分手。在表象之下，还有许多其他复杂的事情在运作。我也认为，如果你有点完美主义，你真的很害怕妥协的想法，或者害怕生活中的某件事在当下不够完美、在未来也不够完美。这可能会导致你以一种如此强烈的审视目光来看待你的亲密关系，以至于你当然会在其中发现不好的地方。所以在那些时刻，问自己这七个问题。我认为这会给你带来一些清晰的思路。首先，当你想象没有他们的生活时，你是感到如释重负，还是感到一种失落感？与他们在一起的未来是让你感到兴奋，还是让你感到畏惧？他们是否以某种方式挑战了我，
that makes me want to get better? Do they reciprocate my energy, my love, my effort? Do I admire who they are, not just what they do for me? Does our relationship feel love? light or does it feel heavy? Would I trust this person to make good decisions about my life on my behalf? Those are our seven questions. I feel like it's a nice little checklist to come back to if you needed it. But as for today's episode, I hope you enjoyed it. I hope that it's given you some clarity on whether you are with the one, whether you are with the right kind of one if you don't necessarily believe in soulmates. And some of the just beautiful, fascinating science behind what makes love last from couples who've been together for decades to the indicators that we
让我想要变得更好？他们是否对我的能量、我的爱、我的付出给予了回应？我欣赏的是他们这个人，还是仅仅欣赏他们为我做出的贡献？我们的亲密关系让人感觉轻松，还是让人感觉沉重？我是否会信任这个人，让他代表我为我的生活做出明智的决定？这就是我们的七个问题。我觉得这是一个很好的小清单，你可以在需要时拿出来重新审视。但至于今天的节目，我希望你喜欢它。我希望它能给你带来一些清晰的认识，让你明白你是否正与真命天子在一起，如果你不一定相信灵魂伴侣的话，你是否正与那个对的人在一起。以及那些长相厮守了几十年的情侣所展现的、让爱长存的科学背后的美丽与迷人之处，还有我们可以从亲密关系最初的几个月里看到的那些指标，它们会告诉你，这是好的还是坏的？这份爱会长存吗？它会消逝吗？所以我希望你学到了很多。我当然学到了。我整周都在和我的朋友们谈论这一集的内容以及我的发现，尤其是那些刚结束约会的朋友，他们会问“他会这样做吗？”或者“她会那样做吗？”所以希望你能将这些知识带入你自己的生活，并审视你自己的朋友们。考虑到这一点，如果你认为他们会从中获得乐趣或者会喜欢这一集，请务必把这一集发给他们。确保你在苹果播客、Spotify或你正在收听的任何平台上关注我们，并给我们留下五星好评。
can see from like the first few months of a relationship that will tell you, is this good, is this bad? Will this love grow? Will it fade? So I hope you have learned a lot. I certainly have. I've been talking about this episode in my kind of, I guess, findings all week to my friends, especially like my friends who are just out of dating people and like, does he do this or does she do that? So hopefully you can bring this knowledge into your own life and scrutiners, your own friends. With that in mind, make sure you send them this episode if you think that they would get a kick out of it or you think they would enjoy it. Make sure you are following along on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening and give us a five-star review.
这真的对节目的成长和发展非常有帮助。嗨，如果你已经收听到了这里，那么，这就是我们在节目结尾设置的秘密俱乐部：如果你坚持到了最后，你就会得到一个表情符号，你可以把它留在下方的评论区。我想我们的表情符号就用一个心形吧。选择你想要的任何颜色。无论哪种颜色最能代表你目前的爱情生活。心形的颜色。我觉得这就好比是对大家目前的爱情状态做个小小的打卡。但再次感谢大家的收听。请确保在Instagram上关注我们。我总是忘记在节目结束时该说些什么。但是是的，请务必在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast，这样你就可以了解接下来会播出什么节目，进一步参与对话，把你的节目建议发给我，我们下周见。注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再次聊起。
It really helps the show to grow and to evolve. And hi, if you have made it this far, well, this is the secret club that we have at the end of the episode where if you make it to the end, you get an emoji so you can leave it in the comments below. I think our emoji would just be a heart. Choose whatever color you want. Whatever, whatever color is best representing your love life at the moment. Color of heart. I think that's like, let's do a little check in on how everyone's feeling about love at the moment. But again, thank you for listening. Make sure you're following us on Instagram. I always forget what to say at the end of the episodes. but yes, make sure you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast so you can know what episodes are coming out next, join the conversation even further, send episodes
这真的对节目的成长和进化很有帮助。嗨，如果你听到了这里，嗯，这就是我们在每集节目末尾设置的秘密俱乐部，如果你坚持听到了最后，就会得到一个表情符号，你可以把它留在下方的评论区。我想我们的表情符号就用一个心形吧。选择你想要的任何颜色。随便什么颜色，最能代表你目前爱情生活的颜色。心形颜色。我觉得这就好比，让我们来简单了解一下大家目前对爱情的感觉。但还是要再次感谢你们的收听。确保在Instagram上关注我们。我总是忘记在节目结束时该说些什么。但是是的，一定要在Instagram上关注我们@That Psychology Podcast，这样你就能知道接下来会推出哪些节目，进一步参与讨论，发送节目
suggestions my way, and we will be back next week. Stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
嘿，你们好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的历课》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出的信号是，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的历课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控为双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次。欧文斯，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱网》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧性、体能和抗逆力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。我们的播客名字叫TWO.%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends, Trust Me, Babe）。
This is an IHartie Heart Podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档iHeart电台播客。品质真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。